écoutez je sais pas moi j'essaye de
démêler cette histoire le président m'a
confié une mission non de choquer mais
qu'est ce qu'on vous a dit plus de
troupes ne demandait plus de troupes et
vous faites quoi vous nous envoyer une
demande de caractère lui ont dit que sa
coupe sans arrêt là vous m'entendez je
vous entends pas oui je vous entends pas
alors là il ya vraiment un truc qui
cloche mais oui général vous nous
entendez là oui je vous entends
j'entends pas ce que vous dites bon ben
je vous laisse des capucins il faut
enchaîner je suis dit vrai vous êtes là
pour nettoyer la merde ce conflit c'est
la merde pas vrai rien quand on parle de
guerre n'est jamais simple pattes
si je suis là c'est pas mon chéri
conflit et je refuse d'être venu juste
pour enterrer cette guerre je suis venu
pour gagner
monsieur le président il faut que vous
agissez en leader mais c'est ce que je
fais je gère hallyday je ne suis pas
disponible
ça se fait qu'ils veulent pas se battre
l'ennemi y en a qui veulent pas se
battre dans la neige mais on peut pas
les aider des tueurs m'a dit c'est
humainement impossible
[Musique]
il dit que les américains disent
niktamère tout le temps et nous
considérons dans notre culture que c'est
mal de [ __ ] sa propre mère donc dans
la nôtre aussi dans la nôtre aussi
il faut que je me retire après la
décision il nous faut nous le dire est
exactement
fo qui me reçoivent en ligne
ivoire dividende avant ce dîner c'est
pour l'afghanistan et vous avez le culot
de me virer le seul afghans présents
dans la pièce de ma table boss en fait
je crois qu'on a anno grave quand ce
soir c'est l'ambassadeur afghan général
les hommes sont des créatures imparfaite
livrés à eux mêmes tout ce qu'il
souhaite au fond c'est se tripoter
l'amiante et manger du poulet
ils ont besoin d'être guidée sam
laissez-moi venir ouais j'suis avec vous
a donné j'ai avec vous je fais quoi moi
pour moi